I would suggest you know just do it take
a test right look at the different
Legends of Giants and see if you can
find the thread of what I'm
[Music]
saying this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to
the symbolic
world
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone as some of you know we
are getting ready we are just about to
launch the new God's dog Warrior
Kickstarter and I thought that as we get
ready to uh start on this new Journey it
would be a great idea to look at the
symbolism of giants because in the
graphic novel of course the bad guys are
the Giants now it's interesting because
we wrote this a long time ago my brother
and I wrote this now almost 15 years ago
at a time where nobody was really caring
about Giants and nobody thought about
that and their relationship to what's
happening in the world today but now
with the Lord of spirits and you know
people like Michael Heiser and also a
lot of conspiracy type uh people the
question of the Nephilim and of giants
is back you know in people's perception
and has been taking up more and more
cultural space and so what I thought we
could do is we could look at the
symbolism surrounding the question of
giants understanding why they appear the
way they do in the different forms how
why there's so much versatility in the
symbolism of Giants and what that can
mean in order to look at the symbolism
of giants we have to we'll take the
biblical and inocent account first as a
kind of standard to look at it and to
understand why it looks the way that it
does and what that can mean and then
we'll see how it plays out in the uh in
the different instantiations that they
have in culture now as you know in The
Book of Enoch and you know base on the
Book of Genesis we have this idea that
the sons of God came into the women uh
the daughters of men and the result of
that were the Nephilim of course in
scripture it's very vague what it is
like what are the Nephilim these Fallen
ones you know who are these Watchers
that are mentioned in the in The Book of
Enoch all of this is a little vague but
when you look at extra biblical
traditions and Al especially how they
connect even to other mythologies from
other cultures you can start to
understand how all of this fits together
and
so the idea is to understand that
there's something from above that mixes
in an appropriate way with something
from below you know whether you
understand it as angels having
relationship with humans uh whether you
understand it as you know the descendant
of Seth that have relationships with the
descendants of Cain in the end the
symbolism is the same it is an improper
Union between that which is above and
that which is below so you could
understand it as an improper Union
Between Heaven and Earth no matter how
you see it and so uh you know if the
idea of the principalities or the angels
having children with humans and you know
producing offspring of course I
mentioned this before father Ste the
young seems to have given us a very good
solution to avoid the problems that this
causes which is that the these types of
relationships were mediated through
ritual and that the way in which someone
would have a relationship with a a God
or principality was through ritual
sexual practice with a priestess or
priest or a temple prostitute and that
this is what would give a powerful being
which came to be understood as what we
would say the the Giants or these these
these Fallen beings that are also
represented at least culturally and at
least in the stories as being
gigantic and if you understand that
that's the basic relationship you can
see that across several stories and
across several Traditions you will find
that that is how the the they're
represented so if you look at the way in
which the Greek Giants are born they are
born out of the castration of Heaven and
the seed of Heaven Fall falling
half-hazard onto the Earth in a
non-planned you could say non uh
purposeful Manner and then creating the
Giants in that accident and so that's
the that's the way to think about it is
something like the the accident of
meaning the side effect of meaning these
are all ways to understand what it is
the Giants are for and you could say
also the excess of body is really the
way to understand it in this case which
is in some ways that the the the meaning
isn't aligned it's it's not aligned
towards what it really should be and so
because of that it creates something
which you could say has a lot of body
but doesn't have a lot of head that has
a lot of body but that doesn't have a
lot of spirit and if you think of just
different ways in which Giants are
represented in popular cultures as um
you know stupid kind of ogre type figure
that is huge but is not very smart this
is of course something that is just very
pervasive in our way we understand our
culture but you can see how all of these
things kind of come together which
is the the bad Union of Heaven and Earth
the wrong Union of Heaven and Earth the
The Accidental Union of Heaven and Earth
which makes it so what you get is
something like a lot of power and very
little Direction a lot of uh you know
you could call them you have more of The
Accidental aspect of the Union of Heaven
and Earth and this is represented of
course also in the way in which the
Giants are are represented in for
example in Greek culture again as
usually some kind of excess you know
beings with a thousand arms or you know
with the legs of serpents they have a
kind of hybrid aspect to themselves or
kind of excessive aspect to themselves
and some of them are huge you know like
Mass massively uh not just you know a
few feet tall but like hundreds of feet
tall or whatever uh and this is to show
this kind of breakdown
now this seems all very mythological you
know and it seems all very strange but a
good way to understand the Giants is
something like Civilization gone wrong
okay this is a way to apply the question
of the Giants to something that you can
understand and that isn't just totally
captured by mythological story telling
it is something like something above
like the head or a king or someone and
the King because of he's a principality
right like a like an angel but in the
world something that is like a god but
in the world joins with a body right
joins with the city makes has this large
body very powerful body that uh that is
aligned with
him and you could say that the gigantic
part or the the Fallen part right the
Nephilim part of that is the the side
effects of the city the way in which the
systems become out of control they
forget what they're for and they take on
a life of their own so they become a
kind of
parasitical uh body that
is not no longer enacting what they
should be aligned towards so think of it
now at different levels it's important
to understand it at different level
levels because if you don't then it's
going to sound weird what I'm saying you
have to understand something like the
Fallen Angel itself is an image of that
that is the for example in scripture the
idea that the Angels rebel against God
or the idea in the the the Greek myths
that the the the Titans who are these
beings created by the meaning of the the
proper meeting of Heaven and Earth that
these Titans rebel against heaven and in
rebelling against Heaven they castrate
the God and that castration that that
wrong relationship between Heaven and
Earth is what gives you know the seed of
Heaven falls on the earth and then
brings about the Giants and so all of
this happens all the way through and so
it's completely aligned with the idea of
the Rebel angels that rebel against God
and then come down to the Earth and have
relationships with women which bring
about
the the Fallen ones because the angels
are not aligned properly the
relationship between the the the angels
and the women on the earth is not a
proper relationship it's misaligned and
so therefore the fruit of that is the
misalignment the Fallen ones the the the
too much body and not enough purpose and
so you now you can apply it more
reasonably to something like a city and
you can understand how that happen which
is the aspects of the city which are
misaligned either towards the King right
towards the president towards the the
marage or the the the corruption that
appears there or the manner in which the
king himself or the mayor himself is
corrupt and is not aligned towards a
higher purpose which will then cause the
fruits of that to become misaligned and
so what you'll have is you'll have
things like tyranny you'll have
corruption you'll have chaos you have
all of these types of of behaviors which
will appear like uh the giant so now now
kind of empty your mind of all the
stories that I've told now think of the
giant in the fairy tale think of the
giant in the popular imagination of how
the giant acts the giant moves around
uses power arbitrarily right will is a
cannibal usually we'll eat humans we'll
sit on things you know we'll break
things we'll you know we'll have a big
club and we'll just start bashing things
around uh and is in some ways a
representation of the forces of
nature themselves right because in the
story of the Greek um theogony for
example the Titans and the Giants they
kind of get banished Down Under the
Earth you know the the the Titans get
put into Hades and the Giants get kind
of put into the ground like they become
the source of volcanoes the source of
earthquakes the source of all of this
and again you can see how it fits
together which is although now we're not
in the human sphere of civilization
we're in the idea of the misalignment of
Heaven and Earth well all of a sudden
the Earth is not acting towards purpose
it is it is being destructive it is not
helping uh purpose come about but is
rather going against purpose and is a
kind of Brute Force without head that is
acting on the world and so just
understanding that can account for all
the different aspects of the Giants and
how they you know how they manifest
themselves as you know we're also
writing a version of Jack and the
beanock and Jack and the beanock is very
interesting because now you have Giants
in the heavens and so you'd think well
if the Giants are these bodies without
heads why are the Giants up in the
heavens that doesn't make any sense
right but that is of course again you
just have to understand it as a
misalignment of Heaven and Earth as the
way in which Heaven is misaligned with
Earth and you can see why it's not weird
to imagine that there are giants uh that
are up above you that they would be
represented that way as something like
leaders that are not acting towards the
higher good right so a leader that is
not acting towards the higher good could
be represented with the tropes of a
giant an OG a cannibal um you know all
the different the different images that
we represent as the as the Giant and so
then you you have again because if you
see it fractally you'll see
that when the giant is represented like
in the story of Jack and the beach as
being in a castle up in heaven you know
he's in a castle he has a kind of kingly
function because he's above you in a
castle uh and so then he's both in some
ways the Fallen Angel and the Giant at
the same time because you can see that
both of those are just different
versions of the same problem which is
why both in the the scriptural text
right the idea that the the sons of God
rebel against God by mixing in properly
with the daughters of women bringing
information bringing wisdom bringing the
knowledge of God down into the world but
in a way that is weaponized right in a
way that is there to give to bring power
rather than to be uh a transparent
vehicle for something higher then that
gives the nephin that gives the Fallen
ones and in the Greek mythology you have
the same image which is that the Titans
rebel against Heaven they castrate they
castrate the gods and then that brings
about the the the Giants and both of
those are are fighting against the gods
and so the both of them ultimately it's
it's in the Greek story it's a little
more complicated cuz then there's a like
a kind of restoration that happens uh to
avoid things from falling further down
so it's not com it's it's not as clear
as what you see in the Christian images
uh which is that Zeus is no is not you
know the is not heaven himself he not
the god of Heaven he's kind of a he's
kind of a figure that stops the chaos
from continuing but nonetheless the
structure is there which is that you
have to fight against the Titans and you
have to fight against the Giants and so
you have the titano Maki and the the the
the giganto Maki which are the two Wars
that the gods have against the Giants um
and then in the Christian world you have
that same type of imagery which is on
the one hand you have the image
of the battle against the the in the
heavens the the Great War in the heavens
where the angels and the demons are are
in a in a battle but then you also have
this kind of imagery in terms of how the
flood will destroy the world of the
Giants how of course there's also this
fight against Gog and Magog in
Revelation which is uh related to this
idea of these kind of you know giant
monsters that that are that are uh too
much body okay so that can kind of help
you understand a a basic structure of
how Giants work now there's another way
that Giants are represented that you can
help you understand what Giants are but
it's the same thing it's just you have
to instead of thinking about it in terms
of a kind of hierarchy of authority and
then the giant the the the
principalities rebelling against what is
above and then that giving birth to the
side effects of of a hierarchy the side
effects of power you can also have it in
something like in time which is that
often in many Traditions the Giants are
represented as that which was there
there before the current order and that
is a way to maybe understand it more in
terms of the way the Greeks represent it
but you also see that of course in noris
mythology and in many other mythologies
where the Giants were there before us
and they are in some ways a remainder of
an ancient world to which we don't have
access anymore that doesn't connect to
our origin um you know if you look at
the way in Scandinavian in the
Scandinavian mythology
you have this idea even that the world
is built out of the body of a giant that
was there before so the world that's
there before is dead and now is
decomposed and now we take the
remainders of that world and we
reorganize it in order to create uh in
the to create the current
world this of course is there also in
the story of Noah which is that now to
it also appears in time which is that
the Giants appear as a remainder
of the pre- deluvian world and this kind
of you know broken chaotic remainder of
what was there before because it is a
place where Heaven and Earth don't meet
which is that we have an origin of our
story we have a foundation of a Nation
the foundation of a of a uh of a culture
of a story and that is the the the order
of that world and it's the manner in
which Heaven and Earth join together and
what preced it is of course something
that we can't understand because it's
like a residue it's a remainder of
something that doesn't make sense to us
and that remainder and things that don't
make sense to us is equivalent to the
natural forces that are in the world
like again of the giant that that was
broken down in Northern mythology in
order to make the new world and you can
think about that in terms of culture so
if there's a if there's a massive change
in culture then that which was there
before has to now be realigned has to be
used as the potential out of which we're
now going to make the the New World um
and and that is akin to coming to a land
and then finding the the land that's
there or whatever is there and then
having to organize it you know to plant
to plant uh food to build buildings to
do whatever in order to make it into now
a habitable place so that is why Giants
also appear as that which was there
before us and so you see that in every
so many cultural stories you'll just see
it nonstop everywhere which is that
whether it's it's Native American you
know different Aboriginal uh mythology
that there were giants there before they
arrived that there were this strange
race of of giant men who are there
before uh you see it in the how the
Brutus from Troy comes to to England to
the British is and what does he find of
course he finds Giants he has to defeat
the Giants before being able to found
his new civilization now that is exactly
the same as the Norse gods or the the
Norse world having to create a new world
out of a previous giant okay um and that
is so pervasive that way of thinking is
so pervasive that no matter how the
giant appears to us the giant will
always have that structure so if you
then move into a world of evolutionary
thinking where humans were are
descendants of apes and that now we're
humans when we see our Giants that is
when we encounter the Giants whether
that encounter is imaginary or not it
doesn't matter we will use the the same
story Trope no matter what so we'll say
that Bigfoot or that you know uh the
different uh giants that are encountered
in the Americas with like was it wendigo
or all these these giants that are in in
American mythology that those are Apes
right they are a world that was there
before our origin the potential out of
which humans have Arisen and they
remainders of that world right there
there the possibility of some kind of
humanoid creature that is not us but
that was there you know before us or
that is is a is a a kind of remainder of
our ancient of our ancient past and so
there's really no way to get around this
type of Mythology and it's a good way to
kind of try to connect all of the
elements of the Giants together and so I
would suggest you know just do it take a
test right look at the different Legends
of Giants and see if you can find the
thread of what I'm saying if you can if
you can notice how the
the the Giants manifest these different
aspects which is really a misalignment
of Heaven and Earth and what that looks
like whether it is in some ways a
kingdom out of control where the power
of the institution is now acting like a
tyranny on us or whatever or whether it
is a Savage uh giant wearing you know
animal skins with a club that's eating
humans all of that manifests this
misalignment Between Heaven and Earth
and so I hope this was helpful and I
encourage you to sign up for God's dog
for the kickstarter we're going to we're
trying to launch around the 30th but we
want as many people subscribe because
we're going to have early bird specials
for those who are willing to to uh to go
in there first um and in this book you
will really will discover you know what
is the relationship between the garments
of skin between you know and these
Giants that appear in the first book and
it's all related to matan's
understanding of this question of of
residues of remainders and of the
prediluvian world and so I really hope
to take all of you along on this trip to
discover the continuation of God's dog
which is called God's dog Warrior and so
thanks everybody for your support and we
will talk very soon bye-bye